[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain a comedy drama film
called secret zoo
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
[Music]
kang tai soo works a dead-end temp
position at a renowned law firm j.h
taisu dreams of one day landing a
permanent position at the firm but so
far he has been unsuccessful taisu's law
firm has been hit with scandal after
scandal currently its vice president min
chul hyun is in prison for stock
manipulation and embezzlement a group of
protesters have been camping outside the
jh headquarters for more than a week to
protest against the firm for being
unjust and exploitative taisu's college
friend song also works at the firm as an
associate the latter always invites
taisu for drinks on the weekends but
taisu doesn't want to face his friends
who are a lot more successful than him
one day jh's ceo mr huang is mobbed
outside the hq by the protesters the
protesters hurl obscenities at hwang
which aggravates him and he gets into a
fight with the mob the mob easily
overpowers swang and seeing his boss in
trouble taisu puts himself in the line
of fire to save him the ceo takes notes
of taisu being manhandled by the crowd
as he drives away impressed by him huang
invites taisu for dinner where he meets
raquan group's vice president and hyun's
sister min che ryung after riyung leaves
huang gets to know more about tai soo
huang promises to give taisu a permanent
position at jh if he manages to
revitalize a failing zoo called dongsan
park that one of jh's uk-based clients
gabriel incorporated has acquired taisu
couldn't be more excited and accepts the
deal immediately however huang gives him
an ultimatum and says that he has
exactly three months to revitalize the
failing zoo in the next scene taisu
quickly heads over to the zoo and lo and
behold he learns that the zoo has no
animals except for a troubled polar bear
and some other animals that no one would
pay to see taisu talks to the remaining
zoo staff and they reveal that the zoo's
animals have been taken away by the lone
sharks that the zoo's previous owners
owed money to the zoo staff consists of
former directors ceo veterinarian han
hai kyung and gun wuk after learning
that tai soo is the new director of the
zoo ceo proceeds to leave but taisu
convinces him to stay saying his
experience will be necessary to bring
this zoo back to life taisu proposes
buying animals but he is told that one
can't buy endangered animals they could
seek special permission for research and
breeding from the government but that
could take well over three months later
that night while returning back to his
living quarters inside the zoo taisu is
given the scare of a lifetime by a
stuffed animal which he mistakes for a
real tiger one of the laid off zoo staff
reveals that he is taking the stuffed
toy to sell it for some money the next
morning taisu relays his problem to
hwang but the latter tells taisu to
return if he can't make it work
realizing that he may no longer have a
future at the company if he fails to
deliver taisu promises to make it work
at any cost taisu then notices pictures
of the zoo's annual soft toy contest on
the wall and suddenly an idea strikes
him he proposes the idea of having the
zookeepers dress up as animals he
stresses that people won't be able to
tell the difference between a realistic
animal costume and a real animal from a
certain distance the zeus staff quickly
get on board in the name of saving the
zoo but han refuses to partake in the
foolishness however taisu plays with
han's heartstrings by bringing up the
story of her becoming a vet because of
the zoo's polar bear black nose
eventually persuading her taisu then
contracts a hollywood costume designer
to design a realistic lion gorilla sloth
and polar bear costume within two weeks
they receive the costumes and co
suggests hiring actors for the job but
taisu turns down the suggestion saying
their secret could get out left with no
choice han hai kyung gun wuk nco become
the lion sloth gorilla and polar bear
respectively and the rehearsals begin
soon the zoo's gates are opened to the
public and it receives groups of
kindergarten kids and senior citizens
the zoo staff initially struggle but
eventually get the hang of their new job
managing to fool the visitors their
effort manages to attract 75 visitors in
a week but the numbers are not enough to
keep the zoo open so taisu insists on
getting a giraffe to learn more visitors
meanwhile hai kyung's boyfriend sung min
dumps her after wasting five years worth
of her savings on a convenience store
near the zoo seeing hai kyung crying
gunwuk storms into the store wearing the
gorilla costume and destroys it sung min
reports the gorilla to the police but he
is brushed aside as a lunatic the
following day sung min shows up at the
zoo where gunwuk again attacks him as a
gorilla exposing their secret in the
process after learning about taisu's
scam seung-min threatens to report them
to the police but hai kyung convinces
him against it and asks gunwuk to
apologize to him later that night taisu
visits his costume designer but to his
dismay he learns that he is taken off
with the deposit leaving behind only the
head of the giraffe in the warehouse
however taisu refuses to give up and he
uses the head of the giraffe to trick
his visitors
soon ceo falls sick from sitting out in
the sun in the hot costume so tai soo
takes over his role he quickly learns
that cosplaying an animal at a zoo isn't
an easy job as some unruly visitors keep
throwing stuff at him taisu also gets
tired of sitting in the sun and when no
one's looking he grabs a coca-cola
bottle thrown by one of the visitors
inside the pit and drinks it to quench
his thirst however some visitors managed
to capture tai soo gulping down the
coca-cola bottle that day a
representative from jh arrives at the
zoo and reveals that tyso's request for
animal purchase has been approved after
giving him a tour of the zoo taisu
manages to send the rep off that night
taisu gets a call from song who tells
him about his plans to visit the zoo
with his kids after seeing jh spending
so much money and effort to keep the zoo
up and running taisu asks song about
gabriel and song reveals that gabriel is
hwang's own shell company that he uses
to manage his slush fund much to thai
sue's astonishment the next day a crowd
of people show up at the zoo and taisu
learns that his polar bear has gone
viral after the video of the polar bear
drinking coke hit the internet tai soo
and his team couldn't be more excited
and thanks to the polar bear the zoo
becomes a massive hit hundreds of people
flock to the zoo every day to see the
bear drinking coke and over the weekend
the zoo makes a massive profit of 100
000 dollars
one day gunwuk finds hai kyung
despairing by herself and talks to her
she is still reeling from her breakup
and gunwuk offers to take her out to
dinner meanwhile tai soo notices black
nose roaming outside in the pit he then
finds han watching an old childhood
video of black nose by herself she
reveals that she let black nose out of
the cage so he could get some fresh air
the two then talk about black nose's
worsening behavior she says that no
matter how spacious the zoo is it is
still a cement cage for the polar bear
she reveals that she once had an
opportunity to send the animal to canada
where it could live in the wild but she
decided to keep it around hoping that if
she did her best it would get better she
laments her decision and thanks tysou
for saving the zoo before parting ways
the next day huang offers taisu a
permanent position at jh taisu is
ecstatic at the news but his happiness
soon turns into disappointment when
huang reveals his plans to bulldoze the
zoo and build a resort raquan group had
purchased over 25 million square feet of
land around the zoo and they also wanted
to buy the zoo itself but huang's shell
company gabriel swooped in and bought it
up huang then ordered taisu to
revitalize the zoo so gabriel could sell
the land to raquan group at a much
higher price taisu tries to convince
hwang against selling the zoo but huang
dismisses him dejected taisu returns to
the zoo to deliver the bad news but he
is surprised by han and the others with
a success party former employees of the
zoo also joined the party and thanked
taisu for giving them their livelihood
back seeing them so happy taisu can't
bring himself to break the bad news
however a former employee of the zoo
from earlier in the movie arrives and
reveals raquan's plans to build a resort
on top of the zoo taisu confirms the
news and the former employees leave
disappointed han and the others feel
cheated by taisu and refuse to hear him
out left with no choice taisu returns to
his new job in seoul and gets on with
his life however he still regrets what's
happening to the zoo when the rakuan
group's team arrives to demolish the zoo
ceo gets into an altercation with the
company staff and injures himself in the
process the zoo staff reunite in the
hospital and han proposes a solution she
suggests opening the zoo and putting
raquen on blast publicly for trying to
demolish it the public campaign works
and the media and environmental
activists get all over raqqan like a bad
rash the development enrages raquan's
vice president ryung and hwang promises
to remove the miscreant employees from
the zoo premises however it fails to
calm ryung down as her attempts to
revamp the image of the company have
tanked badly huang promises to resolve
the problem as soon as possible and
leaves huang is later visited by hai
kyung's ex-boyfriend seung-min who tells
the ceo the truth about the fake zoo
animals taisu notices sung min leaving
hwang's office and figures out that he
has ratted them out huang and his
assistant immediately leave for the zoo
and they're closely followed by taisu
before huang gets to expose them taisu
alerts han and the others about the
development han stops wang from going
into the room where the polar bear is
kept shortly afterwards taisu joins them
and huang warns him to tell him the
truth about the zoo animals but taisu
continues to feign ignorance enraged
huang forces his way into the room and
finds black nose sleeping mistaking the
bear for a fake one huang challenges the
animal almost getting himself killed in
the process to calm black nose han lets
him into the pit while huang proceeds to
leave however huang returns to check the
polar bear again when he becomes certain
that the giraffe is fake huang gets into
the pit with black nose and challenges
him again black nose attacks him and
huang passes out to save his boss taisu
puts on the polar bear suit and lures
black nose away from hwang it works and
twang is brought back to safety but at
the expense of taisu who is attacked by
the bear the angry bear tears taisu's
suit open exposing him but fortunately
taisu manages to run to safety just in
time after the public debacle taisu
apologizes to his team and offers to
take all the blame to protect them
however han and others oppose the idea
saying they are all as guilty as him hai
kyung wishes out loud that they could do
something about blacknose and the other
remaining animals suddenly an idea
strikes tai soo yet again he claims that
he can save the zoo and goes to meet
raquan's vice president ryung he
proposes to run an ecological park for
young's resort where the animals could
live this would not only remove the
roadblock stopping the construction of
the resort but it would also save
raquan's image from being tarnished
further riyoung agrees on the condition
that taisu gets gabriel on board through
his friend song taisu retrieves hard
evidence of huang laundering money using
gabriel taisu then threatens to leak the
documents to the press and police if
huang doesn't agree to sell the zoo to
raqqan reluctantly huang agrees to the
deal
several years passed by and the movie
cuts to a scene of riyung presenting a
video of the rakuan eco park consisting
of various real wild animals seo and
others have been hired by raqqan group
moreover blacknose has immigrated to
canada the movie ends with taisu and han
visiting blacknose in his natural
habitat subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching